[Music]
hello and welcome to this
how the light gets in event my name's
claire armistead i'm an
associate editor for culture at the
guardian and i am
very delighted to actually be meeting
for the first time
a man who i followed whose fortunes i
have followed
avidly since i think 1991 when you first
appeared
well you didn't appear when on the hour
first appeared could it really be that
long ago
amanda unfortunately it is yes
and so if my first encounter with you
was was through the radio
and as as your many other fans like me
will know it went on to the day
today which gave us the great alan
partridge
and then obviously went on to the thick
of it which we will be talking about
today
because um which seemed at the time very
wicked and tough and
now it seems absolutely you know it's
absolutely pussycat you know
handbook of better government really
isn't it and
then of course very more recently um
you've turned to he's turned to um films
with the death of stalin
and um most recently of all the personal
history of david copperfield which
for me seemed like a change of tone
really it seemed because it seemed like
a
as if a love affair with this victorian
novelist which is
which was unusual and surprising and
refreshing and the fact that it happened
you just snuck in before kovit happened
didn't you
yes yes it came out i think it came out
in the uk
cinemas january and february of last
year so it was the first it was the last
film i saw
in fact it's the last film i've seen in
the cinema this i think and i think it
probably has been for a lot of people
yes yes it came out in the the before
times
as we call them now um and
and yeah and it it kind of for me it
didn't feel like a
a radical change it felt like almost
like a coming home because i
you know i i adored dickens writing when
i was like
a teenager i was a very avid reader use
the local
like public library an awful lot and
just dragged all of
dickens and graham green and even war
and you know um
and uh i just loved his his ambition
the fact that he could write these big
novels that were almost like a state of
the nation and yet had very intimate
comedy and
and trauma and tragedy within them
he's very idiosyncratic i know but i
just enjoyed
i i relished the fact that he was he he
didn't mind in fact he
he he got off of being very popular you
know he
he he he was one of those authors who
didn't feel reduced by being very
commercial
and in fact that was the essence of him
his his big audience that he
used this enormous stage that this
public stage he had to talk about
at the time really difficult subjects
like
you know the poor house and and poverty
and crime and
bad schooling and child labour and
things like that
so for me he dickens had always seemed a
kind of
an aspirational figure
um so doing the film version of david
copperfield to me
didn't it felt felt like something that
i'd always had in me
and it didn't feel like a change of time
i can appreciate how
other people might see that as radically
different i mean there's no swearing in
it
no absolutely no swearing it's a family
film
i'm not a swearer you know the swearing
was really because
in doing the thick of it we had to try
and capture the language really
it's all about all like campbell's fault
really isn't it
well and many more and many more so so
has this kept you busy during this year
have you been
out and about canvassing for for awards
uh
well out about via zoom you know
virtually out and about
doing that so you do these kind of late
night sessions
linking up with l.a film critics and um
voters in new york and so on and across
europe
and um it's it's part of
it's it's actually why i quite like
making films
in the you know with television which
you know i've loved and i've done for
the last
whatever it is 25 30 years
i love doing television but with films
apart from now
with films you actually get to meet your
audience because you actually have to go
out and sell them
you have to you go to cinemas and you
you do q and a
sessions in front of audiences um you
you travel around with your film
you take it to you know european film
festivals and and so on
but actually you get a real sense of the
viewing public whereas when you make a
tv show
um you have the security of it with
films you don't know
when it's going to get made or released
or where it's going to get you with
television you do
but what you don't know is you don't
know how the audience are reacting
because you don't see them the audience
are watching your tv programs in
in groups of one and two and three in
their homes
whereas the magic i find of cinema is
is the group the group experience and
that's what i'm missing
that's what um you know the last 12
months
has shut down that live live cinema live
music live theater
and it is going to be the last thing we
return to it's going to be the last
thing to open up
and i hope it's there for us because you
know a lot of us have got through these
last 12 months
by watching movies and by listening to
music and you know by
engaging with culture so i'm sure when
we are allowed out
we will be desperate to kind of share
that experience
in a kind of communal effort so
um i just so you've taken to film just
at the point at which the
the golden age of television i know
i know it's quite perverse but i i kind
of
i always thought i always wanted to make
films but i always
felt that i needed to be confident that
that that i'd learnt enough about how to
go about it and be confident enough and
i i felt i have to do things things like
the think of it and
a larger scale version veep in america i
i then
felt i could i could take it on um
i also feel yes i know i'm aware i'm
kind of going against the trend really
because a lot of
you people like martin scorsese are all
gravitating towards
doing television um i
i did something magical about that
one-off like i said first of all the
communal experience
the the watching something in a room
with you know 200 other people
and also the one-off nature of this
self-contained and
and once you watch something on a big
screen you're so absorbed by it you know
you're taken in by
if it's working that you know you come
out of yourself for like an hour and a
half to two hours
you see and i find you know with
television
it can do that short for me that short
amount of concentration but then i get
fidgety and
you know i start seeing beyond the
screen um so i like
that i think what what is going to
happen is that the two are going to
emerge you know we're going to make
cinematic television more and more and
we're going to make movies that
have and they're much more raw a bit
like
television used to be you know
documentaries and
verite and slightly more experimental
so i think it's quite a good time to be
making films actually
um you have also been doing television
because you did have
five yes and you have been working on
that
in this year the second year so the
first series went out last year
the second series quite a bit of
lockdown we were writing second series
we started shooting it in november and
stopped after two weeks because it just
became that's when that new variant
hit us we shoot just outside london we
could tell that some
one weekend the number of cases that we
were having
within our production had suddenly
spiked so i
would i just shut it down um and then we
thought
we could really return until things got
safer so we're still
shut down but the plan is to open up and
start filming again when it's safe to do
so it's a little bit late in the year
where did that come from that's again
that's a bit of a departure
for those who don't know it's a um it's
set in a
in 40 years time and it's looks at the
world of space tourism
and avenue 5 is a large kind of cruise
line a ship
that um spaceship that's that takes 6
thousand people
to saturn and back in uh it meant to be
in eight weeks but something goes wrong
and they miss uh they miss the kind of
anger that they have to hit a certain
moon around saturn by they miss it by a
few degrees
and it's going to take them eight years
um and there the sci-fi
element ends it's fundamentally an
existential comedy it's about six
thousand people having to kind of
come up with their own society and start
from scratch and try and
work out the rules and who's in charge
uh
how you know how does leadership work um
do we have any kind of hierarchy and so
on so it's really about that
plus the fact that they're all trapped
um so can i hear a nerve really because
that went out as
as we were hitting lockdown i mean it's
very very topical
actually in a strange way yes there's
there was one
there was one episode where people
started going out the airlock because
they were convinced
that they weren't in space at all and it
was all a massive conspiracy and they
were on earth
and if they just went out the airlock
they'd be that uh be welcomed back by
their families then
they'd won the reality show um
except they're not they're in space so
you see some of them leave the airlock
and just
freeze and die in space and despite that
others within it are insisting it's all
special effects and they go out
and they freeze and die in space and
despite that
more people would say no no that's just
more special effect and they
they and that was happening that episode
went out
the same week in america people were
banging
um on department stores asking to be
opened up
and you know to be allowed out to be
that there was no such thing as the
virus it was all a hoax
they didn't want to wear masks and so on
and the two sort of
existed side by side and i just thought
but this is bizarre because we wrote
this a year and a half ago
trying to try to think of the stupidest
behavior
we could come up with um and
and it just reminds you that nothing is
stranger than reality
well it is it is sort of conspiracy
theory is central isn't it
yes if only they could let themselves
out of the spacecraft we'd be all much
better off
yeah yeah yeah or or you know it's i
mean you see it
at the moment with you know in america
exists in two
self-contained bubbles each of whom
thinks that their
president is the legitimate president
you know so the trump supporters
believe the thing was stolen and the
biden supporters believe he won
and and there's no meeting in the middle
and and and more and more as
as you know as the internet as social
media
perpetrates these these lies that look
like truth
because on a screen everything looks
roughly the same
people grew up with just a different a
set of beliefs and a belief system and
an
aversion of reality there is completely
divorced
from the version of reality held by the
neighbor and that's
the sort of frightening state i think
we're in at the moment is that a good
place for a satirist or a bad place
it's a terrible place i mean yes i'm
sure you can kind of
i'm sure i think that's the point where
everyone satirist or comedian writer
says i would rather it was just better
you know
fine it might give me a few ideas but
fundamentally i would like the world i
live in to be a bit better
you know because otherwise people die
you know that's the problem
like in america because they don't
believe covert exists or
did they believe that the vaccines are
injecting bits of
bill gates into us um people die
you know and and and even as they're
dying they're convinced it's
joel biden that's done it or or whoever
uh maybe some of them are convincing
themselves that they're not dying and
actually in fact they've just been
drugged by you know some left winger
and they'll wake up the next day i don't
know and that's that's the frightening
thing and i think we're
that's you know that
that issue is beyond it it doesn't
require satire really it
requires immediate help
from from people in responsible
positions
have you been um glued to televisions do
you is that how you absorb
what's going on i have a very kind of
i've
i i think lots of people have
experienced this i've lost all sense of
what is current and what isn't i dip in
and out but we might watch some programs
that were made five years ago we might
watch a film
from 20 years ago i've lost that sense
of what's just been issued this week
what's on this week what's out this week
what's in the news this week um i've
lost that sense i think we've all
become i mean it's been quite
pleasurable actually you know
not feeling pressurized into being on
top of
what's currently out and actually being
able to just look at the whole back
catalogue of
movies and television uh and
documentaries and
and actually just choose something that
as a family you might want to watch or
you know you might want to watch uh
something to them chat
chat about afterwards i kind of there's
been a we've been doing a lot with music
i think you know because everything is
now available on spotify or apple or
whatever
you don't get that sense of what's
current and what was three months ago
it's just all there
so you have done you've done an opera
libretto haven't you so
yes i have yeah i'm a bit of a classical
music kind of um
uh fan uh anything after 1820 i'm a bit
lost
but um yeah i know i love i love
classical music
well they see i grew up in a flat in
glasgow with two older brothers and i
shared a room
with one of my brothers who was into
deep purple and lou reed and david bowie
so all
fine but as a sort of reaction against
that
i just played classical music very
loudly
go back to that library i was talking
about this live hill head library that
opened up
100 yards from our door and had an
amazing
vinyl collection and the great thing
about libraries is you know you can take
a risk because you're not buying it
that you know i can i can take out music
that i've never heard of by someone i've
never heard of
and listen to it if i don't like it i
just bring it back
um it's great and that i learned
everything from that library really
so where did this satirical bent of
yours come from
i don't know i mean i was always a huge
fan myself and my brother actually would
listen to lots of radio comedy with
hitchhiker's guide to the galaxy
radioactive news quiz weekending so on
sorry i have my clue which is still
around um so
that that just i just
we just found that very i just love the
inventiveness of it the
the world the pictures that you know
built up in your head it felt very
kind of freeing as well and so there was
that
i grew up billy cornley was just
beginning to to get
well known in glasgow and then you know
throughout the uk at that time
so that was an influence and um
i don't know i don't know whether it's
the
you know growing up in an italian family
but in scotland and
and and feeling partly in and partly out
you know i suppose any first or second
generation
immigrant uh families would say this
this this thing of
you know are you are you part of the
community or are you separate from
you know and it's actually the answer is
both you know so if i went to a very
scottish event like a kaylee
um i think this is a bit weird but if i
then went to a very italian event like a
kind of
big italian wedding i think this is a
bit weird you know so i'm
i'm slightly and my actual
career has been slightly that kind of
um overlap between two diff you know
i've been
i've been an italian in scotland and
then for you know i started off and as
i've worked as a scot in england for
quite a bit of my time
last 10 years i've been a great in
america
um so it's always that slightly watching
something maybe it's giving you that
ability to
to stand back a bit and then for you can
see
how overall something like just looks
really weird
was it partly to do with the a group the
group you had around
you you were working with people like
chris morris
yes but then but at school i was always
the one who would do
um you know like for we we got the
school always used to do this fundraiser
for
an old folks home around the corner
every twice a year and i was always i
would always end up comparing it and
doing jokes and
writing comedy for it and stuff and then
at university
i'd do i'd write review and one-man
shows and
stuff for enbre festival in revenge
stuff so
so there was that i was very lucky when
i i became
a radio comedy producer as well
fundamentally my first
job after i i i worked up in comedy in
scotland and regis scotland as a
presenter
for a youth music program a terrible
alignment given that i
know nothing about any music after 1820
but i was allowed to write comedy and i
was allowed to be
funny and there i was allowed also to
work with other actors it was a
fantastic training
work with other actors and sound effects
and sound engineers and
and produce and direct really and then
my
then i came down to london as a radio
comedy producing radio shows that i grew
up listening to so producing the news
quiz and
weekending and so on and it was there
that i was very lucky there is that kind
of corridor culture where people just
drift in and out
working on lots of other shows you you
gradually get to know certain writers
who
whose sensibility challenge with euros
meet maybe some up-and-coming
new um comics or impressionists or
or stand-ups um
that again you think there's something
interesting there so yeah
so we came together for on the hour the
thing i started off with which was this
parody of the news the cat
the company as it were for that show
were put together for that show so i
knew some of them beforehand
but no i knew rebecca front and david
schneider um
but patrick marber i hadn't worked with
chris morris i hadn't worked with
steve coogan i hadn't worked with you
know as a producer
i kind of put that team together for
that show
and we immediately clicked as well as
the writers liam herring and
peter bainer um we all
immediately clicked and and it's very
kind of satisfying that actually 30 odd
years later we're still all
working together in various combinations
still um you know david schneider helped
write the death of stalin with me
um yeah and that that brings me on to
the question of ownership
um and you do i mean you know alan
partridge
is everybody always thinks of alan
partridge as steve coogan
yeah what is your center how much do you
own that character that was your
intention
it's it's always it's a weird one i i
mean you know officially it's
the characters myself patrick and steve
kind of
formulated the the character and fleshed
him out but fundamentally
steve is alan as it were in the you know
i'm never going to stop
steve from doing an allen partridge that
if he wants to do it you know i'm never
going to be the one that steps and say
well legally
you know yeah uh you know i we're never
going to recast alan
and i mean and it happened very quickly
you know as we were doing on the
hour i said to steve we need a sports
reporter we don't have a sports
reporting can you do a sports reporter a
kind of generic
voice not a not an impression but a
voice that
kind of just seems to sum up and he came
up with this you see obviously i can't
do it as well as steve but he came up
with this yes this very
slightly more mortony slightly more john
watson at the time
and he and as soon as he started
speaking like that we all fell about
laughing and somebody and we could never
remember who said what but somebody said
he's an allen and then someone else said
and a partridge
i mean it was just so he sort of allen
partridge
kind of evolved like like you know he
was like
almost did he yeah just fully formed
aged whatever it was
35 or something like it like like a full
that's born and it can get up and
start walking around you know he was
within seconds he was doing commentary
and and steve said it always helped they
didn't really know very much about sport
so that when he was being allen doing
commentaries he was genuinely just
making it up as he went along not not
really knowing
what he was talking about and it gave it
that air of kind of
alan slightly flailing around now i want
to go
i mentioned time trumpet earlier because
i did my research on time trumpet and
it had some very interesting things in
it sort of little story lines one of
which was
um was the the riot the rise to power of
the bmp
given that this was 2006 after david
following
david cameron's 20 days as prime
minister now david cameron
hadn't been prime minister was not to be
prime minister for another four years
even after it was screened what what
and that's whatever happened to him what
happened here exactly we had a few more
than 20 days and did a bit more damage
and we portrayed the bnp as a very much
more having gone through a major image
refit and been quite
um you know trying to change their image
so that it looked a bit more
respectable and a bit more conventional
i think fundamentally
you know you saw elements of that in
some of the members and some of the
supporters of uk
i'm not going to say the whole of you
kit was like that but there was an
element within uk
who were clearly far right
and but thought if they wore a tie and a
jacket and
um you know you know behave themselves
that that somehow managed to get support
but you you got all these strange people
who once you investigated what they were
saying
online you could see where they were
coming from
but it seems oddly sort of weirdly
prescient because you might david
cameron might not even you know in four
years later he might not even have been
leader of the tory party anymore but
i mean the thing about these it's the
same with sci-fi
you know sci-fi it you know it
declares itself as talking about the
future but it's not really about the
future it's always about the present
all it does is take the present and then
twist one thing
um and and something like time trumpet
which was
done in 2006 but was meant to be done in
a program from
30 years time looking back at 2006 as it
were
um was really you know a way of
projecting the news so not necessarily
being topical in a kind of
detail topical let's make a joke about
what's happened that week but
but trying to gauge just
the the the state of the nation at that
time and
and then just giving it a kind of then
ramping it up to
11. do you think
uh moving on um um to the thick of it
or back to the thick of it do you think
you could do a
a a boris era actually we're not allowed
to call him boris now we have to call
him johnson don't we
um but do you think you could do a trump
johnson
era think of it i think um
i think someone could but it doesn't
have to be the thick of it in term you
know in
you know think of it was done as a very
naturalistic kind of behind the scenes
um but i think it it it
it's it survived on the basis of
you know worked on the principle that
there were certain we all agreed there
was a certain
set of rules by which politics should be
conducted
and what we were doing was showing how
politicians and their
staff slightly bent those rules
trump said there are no rules
you know so you know you can't show me
bending the rules for comic effect
because i don't believe in rules
you know i'm not going to follow any
rules the rules are all broken now
what are you going to do so i think
actually rather than taking a format
from wherever it was 10 years ago and
trying to you know the response to trump
or the response to johnson or the
response to anyone really
is is try and think of the best way
of of of examining them there's a
there's a
you know there's a a lot of comedy that
works for me anyway
it's comedy that has a slightly more
journalistic quality to it now like
john oliver and his team of researchers
a lot of the american
late shows are very forensic in their
examination of what's been happening and
they do research and they look through
the archives and they
do a bit of investigating and it's
interesting i think maybe
because you know because someone like
boris johnson relies on the fact that
he's a kind of
entertainer and that he will hold our
gaze and our attention by being
entertaining it's really
the comedians have had to be the
journalists um
as a sort of you know reaction to that
um
so so it is this an area you're thinking
in is this possibly what you're going to
be doing we're going to see you doing
next
i don't know i never quite no i mean
there is never a plan
things just normally you know after i've
finished a project i normally try and
kind of decompress and for a while and
then something pops up
and i never know in advance what that
thing is that's going to be
going to pop up but as soon as it pops
up i get excited about it so
so you know someone sent me the graphic
novel of the death of stalin it was a
french graphic novel and
i never saw myself as someone who does
other people's you know
adapts other people's work but the
moment i started reading i thought
this is my film this is the next film
i'm going to be what was it that
appealed to you so much about it
it was i mean i had coincidentally i had
been thinking about doing a fiction
about a dictator a british dictator and
inventing one
just to kind of examine how could this
possibly happen
um but then you know reading the events
of stan and it was so absurd the fact
that i mean it opens with a
i think that happened in the there's a
concert taking place in moscow it's been
transmitted live on radio moscow it's a
piano concerto mozart piano concerto at
the end of it
the engineers in the back of the whole
get a call from stalin saying
i've been listening to it can i have a
recording please i'll send someone
around to pick it up
they put the phone down and they turn to
each other and say did we actually take
that
well no no live oh my god we're going to
be killed we're going to be killed
such was the terror that people had of
stalin that they then ran out
shouted to the audience stay in you're
not going home lock the doors
we're going to do this again because we
need to do it for stalin
at which point the conductor fainted
because he was just terrified
so that they've lost a conductor so now
in the film they then go out and get
another conductor in the middle of the
night who comes
in his pajamas and um dressing gum to
conduct
in real life he actually got through two
more conductors because they hold one in
but he was drunk
so they then hold had to hold a third
one in who did it in his pajamas and
dress again
and things like that because they're
true and absurd i just felt that's the
story
because the only way we can convey the
horror and the terror that stalin um
imposed on his country is by through
that absurdist kind of heightened comedy
that's why i'm saying earlier about
meeting your audience i you know when i
was showing the film i'd meet people
afterwards
who grew up understanding and they said
it's true
because it's funny it happened and it
was absurd
so you i mean you've had this you sort
of seem to be able to do whatever you
want whoever i can't even imagine that
the meeting in which you proposed doing
the death of stalin as a
victim have you ever had a
have you ever had a mistake is there
something you regret in your career oh
there's
there is stuff but you know i've made
the old pilot here there that's never
seen the light of day and thankfully
and um i there are scripts film scripts
that in the end
i've never made it um i mean my
philosophy has always been just keep
going you know don't
you know when you do something that if
it's great if it's
if it's been successful that's great but
don't then
try and do the same thing again just
pretend it never happened
and therefore try and think of try and
approach each
project as if it's your first one and
therefore you've got to be as
enthusiastic and as
energetic about that as you were about
the one you did
20 years ago but i like to try and keep
the variety going but my a lot of my
career has been based on
whenever i'm doing a project i always
have another one at the back of my mind
because
the one i'm currently on could all fall
apart
or if there are too many people saying
no we don't like this we don't have
am i ready to walk away so i've always
got to build in my head i kind of
if i walk away have i got something to
walk away to
so as long as i do that i seem i seem to
get by
thank you very much armando fantastic
you're very good company as i had
expected
and thank you very much thank you very
much
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today
to the institute of art and ideas at iai
tv
you